the Gospel of Mary is a relatively short
book it's a text to offer some really
interesting theological positions
contrary to those of mainstream
Christianity as well as tackling topics
of gender and the leadership of women
through placing the figure of Mary at
its Center as a primary disciple and
maybe even heir to Jesus this High
status and role of Mary is really
interesting given the later attitudes in
Christianity towards women teachers in
the church here it is Mary who comforts
the other disciples after which she
starts teaching telling them about what
the Savior taught only her in secret to
forget about the material and focus on
the soul and the spiritual a teaching
that we are to turn inward to our true
selves to find the Divine realm there be
on your guard so that no one deceives
you by saying look over here or look
over there for the child of humanity
exists within you follow it those who
search for it will find it